august the 31st 2021 the day the final
u.s military plane left kabul airport
bringing to an end 20 years of american
presence in afghanistan
the u.s left behind stacks of military
equipment from aircraft to guns adding
to the hall of weaponry the taliban had
been gathering in recent months taken
from the afghan army as it retreated
so what kind of equipment do they have
now and how dangerous could it be
taliban members entered the former u.s
military section of the airport just
hours after the withdrawal
these fighters members of the elite
badri 313 unit can be seen inspecting
ch-46 c night helicopters
this is one of three hangars in the
military zone of the airport
a video filmed later on on the north
side shows an md 530 helicopter is one
of 43 kept in afghanistan by the afghan
air force
next to it a light plane supplied to the
afghan air force by the americans
the us department for defense has spent
nearly 1.8 billion dollars on building
training and equipping the afghan air
force since 2019
the figure spent across 20 years
is far greater
but while images of taliban fighters
surrounded by sophisticated planes and
helicopters is a concern the reality
could be quite different
the head of u.s central command has said
that all 73 aircraft at kabul airport
were made unusable by the americans
analysis of satellite images from
neighboring uzbekistan found that at
least 45 aircraft had been moved to an
airfield there
21 light attack aircraft and tens of
helicopters including black hawks can be
seen on the tarmac in uzbekistan however
the taliban are in possession of some
aircraft that are still usable
this video shows taliban fighters flying
a soviet era mi17 helicopter near herat
at least one uh-60 blackhawk helicopter
was seen being flown by the taliban in
kandahar province the afghan air force
had 33 of these iconic american choppers
in afghanistan at the end of june what
really alarms me i think and what alarms
out of afghans now is the the potential
that you have a blackhawk helicopter
being brought to bear on
a village potentially say of hazaras you
know a community that they targeted in
1990s
in in acts of violence that hazards
regarded as genocide so that balance i
think that the kind of their capacity to
rule afghanistan more completely in a
more
brutal way actually is a major concern
and it's not just aircraft countless
videos of the taliban seizing huge
caches of weapons have circulated in
recent months as they swept across
afghanistan
with the ak-47 the taobao managed to
defeat the world's most powerful
military alliance in the united states
and nato and they did that largely with
you know small arms
this guy's alex gawford met members of
the taliban
whoa
she was shown a hall of 900 guns and
dozens of vehicles from a deserted
afghan army base in wardock province
thousands of u.s humvees are also
thought to have been seized by the group
but just like the aircraft some have
been taken across the border and out of
the taliban's hands this video shows a
convoy of afghan forces in american
humvees heading into iran
this military hardware will bolster the
taliban's capabilities but they've also
been left equally dangerous information
handheld devices used by the us army to
collect biometric data on afghans
working with them are also said to have
fallen into taliban hands this
information could be used to track those
down who have worked with western forces
the pentagon says it does not know how
much equipment could now be in the
taliban's hands
and as more and more footage of taliban
fighters operating old u.s and afghan
military kit continues to emerge the
true cost of leaving these things behind
is yet to be seen
they will use those weapons
not in a way that suggests they're
reformed but in fact they will go back
to really which their instincts which
are to you know rule
with an iron fist